hello everybody this is a talk about
local problems entries
from two perspectives one is the
perspective of distributed algorithms
and the other will be perspective of
descriptive combinatorics
so let me start by giving you a short
summary what this talk is about
so in computer science we have the sub
field where we study distributed
algorithms
using some models one of them is called
the local model of distributed computing
in math there is this sub area called
descriptive combinatorics where
mathematicians study certain
infinite constructions that are in that
are in some sense open
uh it turns out that there are some
practical connections between these two
fields and this is what this talk is
about
i'm going to start by giving you some
definitions
so let me start by defining this local
model of distributed computing
so in this model you have a huge graph
on any nodes think of internet and you
should really think about each node as
being a computer
now these computers they can communicate
via via links
and they communicate in a synchronous
message passing rounds
so everything is very simple there is no
asynchrony
also to make everything very simple we
say that the messages that these
computers can send can have unbounded
size
and also we do not restrict the
computation that these computers are
doing
[Music]
now
at the very beginning of the algorithm
the nodes now only let's say some
reasonable bound on the number of
vertices
and
in case of deterministic algorithms
they know their unique identifier
in case of randomized algorithms
each node has a random string
now the problems we are trying to solve
our problems like coloring let's say
proper coloring and
so what we require is that in the end
every node should know
its part of output so if it is coloring
every node should know its color
the measurement of time complexity here
is very simple it is just the number of
rounds until all the nodes finish
so the model is super simple
in this talk
we will further
restrict our attention to constant
degree graphs to make things even
simpler
and even more we will actually restrict
our attention to regulatories so i i
should our counter will be just about
regular trees so i should define what do
i mean by a regular tree
so you know this could be an example of
regular regulatory it is kind of
branching up to that of logan
also remember if you are talking about
deterministic algorithms then every
vertex of the tree has to have a unique
number this is this unique identifier
but for me this is also regulatory so in
in general uh regulatory for me is a
tree where every vertex has either
degree delta
or it is released
so we would restrict our attention from
now on just for this trees to make
things simple
now i should also tell you what are the
problems that we are going to consider
so here are some examples of so-called
local problems let me go over them
quickly
some
[Music]
it's a problem where you need to
color some notes let's say black
so that the black notes are not
neighboring
and every uncolored white note has at
least one black name
so it is inclusion wise maximal not
maximum
another example and this will be the
running example
in this talk is perfect matching where
we need to select some edges
so that every vertex is matched
the unique neighbor
and proper coloring is another example
this is free coloring
and this is a solution to carving
so in general local problem is just any
problem that you can check the solution
locally
like in two coloring
you can just check that all your
neighbors have different color than you
have
one thing that i should make clear
is that
we somehow in my definition of local
problems we will not care about how the
solution looks like in these for example
in this perfect matching
you could say that there is no solution
to perfect matching if the number of
nodes is bought
okay that's nice but i don't want to
study these kind of global arguments so
whether i will say that i don't care
about that release are matched or not
and this is the problem that i'm going
to start
so these are local programs these are
problems that we are going to talk about
in this talk
and
somehow once we have defined the model
once we have restricted our attention to
some class of graphs while we have once
we have restricted our attention to some
subpass of problem maybe we can now hope
to prove some interesting theorets
and indeed
there is a lot that is known in this
particular setup and this is a result of
many papers over uh several years
and somehow the highlight really or
somehow the nice thing that you know is
that
uh
we understand that organical problems
can be somehow
partitioned into five different
subclasses
so let me now go into these five classes
so first class contains problems that
you can solve in constant number of
distributed routes it doesn't scale in
the size of the graph if problems were
very interesting for us it
contains
the
the two simple problems like color
everything is covered black
this class is already much more
interesting
and this is cause of problems that you
can solve with deterministic or
knock star and steps and prime example
of a problem in this class is maximum
independence
next class contains problems that you
can source in log organ rounds
randomized algorithm or logan ground
deterministic algorithm
an example of that of problem in that
case would be three coloring
the next parts will be most interesting
for this talk and this is the class of
problems that you can solve with the
deterministic or randomized algorithm
that has complexity logan
an example of a problem in this class is
our example of perfect matching
and finally there is this final
family of classes
that
contain problems that you can solve in
time which is k root of n for some
integer k
and an example of a problem in this
class is this two common problem
so two coloring problem is an example
for k equal to
and that's just because that if your
graph
looks like the caterpillar that we have
seen in the previous slide
and one end of the caterpillar decides
to
be colored white
then this information needs to propagate
through the whole caterpillar to the to
the other part
so you really need 10 local rounds
until
until you can solve this problem
so again this top card will not be so
interesting for us
or i should i should by the way say the
family of classes it's not so
interesting for us because these
problems are somehow a little bit too
hard for us
so let me know switch topics entirely
and let me talk a bit about this
descriptive combinatorics
so there is no way i can introduce all
the relevant mathematics
but at least let me try to give an
example of what are the problem that
people study in this field
so here is a very specific problem
i give you
a square of unit area
and scissors
and i ask you
to cut some constant number of shapes
or calculate this square into a constant
number of shapes
and then to translate these shapes so
that they give you
a
circle
of unit rm
so is this possible or not
so if your pieces are really cut by
scissors and they are somehow nice then
it is not so hard to show that it is not
possible
but whatever pieces are measurable so
measurable is somehow a way of saying
that
they are
the pieces are decent but we are not
somehow relying on some weird axiom of
choice constructions
so it is still possible to cut this
square into constant number of
measurable meaning decent pieces
and then rearrange them to unit circle
well it turns out and it's quite
surprising i think that the answer now
is yes
it really is possible
[Music]
so this is an example of a problem that
people study in descriptive
combinatorics
and let me now kind of jump to the
conclusion
[Music]
so in descriptive combinatorics as in
distributed algorithms you can define
some classes of local problems
we have seen these five buckets
in distributed algorithms
and you can do something similar in
descriptive combinatorics so for example
you can define
response uh
which would include all the local
problems
that you can solve with
border construction whatever that means
so let me know
i i that there is no way i can kind of
define this thing formally but let me at
least give you a way of how you can
think about these kinds of problems
so here is how you should think about it
so you are not given an infinite
regulatory but a finite thing
and you can ask for
an article that will give you two kinds
of constructions
so one thing that you can do is that you
can do constant constructions this is
really kind of the same as what you can
do in distributed algorithms
i the other thing you can do is that you
can ask for a maximum independent set
it can also be a maximum independence on
the power graph of the tree meaning that
the selected nodes are farther away than
in normal independent set
and if if you can kind of ask an oracle
for maximum independence financially
many times and you can do these
one constructions it would actually
exactly correspond
to
a class local rockstar n which we have
seen
a few minutes ago when i was talking
about distributed algorithms
but now here comes the difference
so in this card url you can ask for
these two constructions you can do them
countably many times
not financially many times this will be
distributed algorithm but comfortably
many times
and this is how you should think about
this cardboard somehow it's very similar
to distributed algorithms but really the
difference is that you know in this
infinite mathematics
doing something countable times is
actually a very
very reasonable thing to do
and this is why this definition gives
you something a little bit different
than what we are kind of considering
in distributed algorithms
so by the way this is actually not we
we are not able to prove that this is
exactly the same as the definition of
path morale
as far as you know the glass bottle
could include some other constructions
but i i think you shouldn't care about
this i i think that this is kind of a
nice way of thinking
about constructions in the script with
comparators
so this is all very interesting so it
seems that
kind of these two fields could have some
connection because if you kind of
translate what these fields are doing
then it seems very similar
and this is something that was realized
few years ago by bernstein so he has
this he had this very insightful paper
where he kind of formalized some
connections between local algorithms and
descriptive combinatorics
for example one thing that he has proven
is that
this class
of distributed
uh grip scars from distributed
algorithms causes problems that you can
solve in rockstar and many rounds it's a
subclass of these moral constructions
and actually once you kind of understand
how these things are defined
it is actually like pretty simple so
that's all super nice
so
we can kind of draw this picture where
on the left we have these five classes
from distributed algorithms these are
these five different buckets where we
cannot know that every problem is in one
of these five pockets
and then we can start
looking at the classes in descriptive
comparator x and we can start
you know drawing all the possible arrows
that he can draw and this is basically
the end of this paper so here's this
this one arrow that i just discussed
that
that bernstein has proven
and so here is something that we proved
in this paper
so there is this other class of
constructions in in columns
constructions in descriptive
computatorics called bear constructions
so again it has some reasonable
mathematical definition
but i don't want to go into this
and one thing that we prove is that this
class is actually
equivalent
to this class of constructions
that are distributed
and need logan rounds so i think that
whenever you find an equivalence between
two kind of like different fields it's
always very nice right because it is
really growing just in one direction but
we really understand
now that somehow these two
concepts really captured exactly exactly
the same kind of problems
so i now want to give you
kind of a glimpse of how a result like
this can be proven
[Music]
so this is the theorem
so actually
in this case we are kind of lucky
because it turns out that both of these
parts that somehow this class
or focus
or there
has a nice combinatorial description
somehow we understand very well what
makes a problem what makes a local
problem to be included in this class
and here is a definition that kind of
captures this combinatorial condition
so it's
so so we say that the problem is
so-called helpful
if every two sufficiently far away
configurations can be extended to the
right solution so here is what it means
i want to
go back to our example of perfect
matching and this program is helpful and
i want to explain what it means
so suppose i give you some regulatory
maybe it looks like this maybe this is
just a small small part of the tree
and i have write two vertices here one
here one here and i somehow tell you how
how i give you some solution to the
perfect matching problem
around this left vertex and around this
right vertex for example i say that i
will take this edge to my perfect
matching and that edge to my perfect
matching and now i ask you whether it is
possible to extend these two partial
solutions to a solution on the whole
tree
and it is possible
you can kind of
take
the adjacent to perfect machine like
this and then you can extend it to the
home tree
for example you can do it even if the
number of nodes in between have
different parity
then maybe the extension will look like
this
so the perfect machine has this nice
property that we call helpful where this
l is some parameter which is kind of
telling you how far
these two balls need to be restaurant to
make this work
so this property does not matter of
course for example for two coloring you
don't have this property
if i give you two vertices like this and
i say this guy is colored red this guy
is covered right
and you should extend this to do
coloring maybe it will not be possible
because
somehow this guy already
basically implies how the countering
looks like on the whole tree and maybe
the parity will not match
so this is already nice because we
actually understand that this condition
of being helpful is really
equivalent to being in this class of
local also then
which means that now if you want to
prove that the causal of logan is equal
to the cause of better solutions we need
to prove two theorems
one theorem is that you are in local or
spoken if and only if you are helpful
for some l and the other thing is that
you are in caspar if and only if you are
alpha for example
so fortunately for us the second part
was already proven by bench line so we
just proved the first part
that
uh whenever you have distributed
algorithm
of complexity over slogan it means that
you are alpha and right vertebra
and to prove this result we use the
technology
that was developed by chan kenpati
in your previous work
so unfortunately both of these theorems
are kind of complicated so i cannot
really explain what our domain proof
ideas but instead i want to
give you two examples
one example is that i want to show what
is the reason why perfect matching is in
this classroom program and the other
example is that i want to show you the
reason why perfect matching is in this
descriptive
combinatorics class there
and these two reasons are actually a
little bit different
and this will allow us to
have some intuition about what it is
currently saying
so first let's start with perfect
matching let's say i want to prove that
there is a distributed algorithm for
perfect matching that means just look
and rounds
and this can be proven by a classical
technique from distributed algorithms
called raycon complex decomposition
and in this technique we start with a
tree
and we kind of
mark all of its vertices
and we do it by
repeatedly applying two things
so the first thing is that we mark all
the leaves of the two
and the second thing that we apply
is that we look at the rest of the tree
and we
erase or mark all of the paths of the
tree that have at least some small ones
like here the ones this at least two
so we can start by marking all the
leaves and green then we look at all the
paths we mark them as blue
then we again look at all the
greens in the remainder of the graph we
mark them as violet
then there is no path but
then again we try to erase these and
finally this is the messiah
and then somehow you can prove that
after all of logan steps
when you are just repeating these two
iterations
you erase the whole thing
so now when you have the composition or
a tree you can somehow go from the other
side and you can solve your problem
so here is what you do you start with
the the final leaf that we took out of
the tree and you construct the solution
for the leaf meaning you arbitrarily
match it to some of its neighbors
and then you look at somehow the next
class on the menu which are the final or
violent vertices and you extend the
solution to these violent vertices so
these violent vertices again match
arbitrarily but you can't really match
to somebody who is already matched to
somebody
so you continue like this in this
session
and basically if you think about it
we are now exactly using the fact that
perfect matching is helpful
to say that the solution can always be
extended
so you're connecting this extension
until the solution is extended to the
full tree
possibly except for least but this is
this is fine this is what we allowed in
the definition of the solution to own
the problem
so this is how you prove that perfect
matching has a distributed algorithm
that has nothing rounds
let us now
switch a bit and let's talk about what
is the reason why perfect matching is in
this class there
so this graph there it has very like
frightening definition that i don't want
to go into
but really there is a certain
combinatorial construction that is kind
of
captured by this class that is allowed
in this class and this combinatorial
construction is called stones so let me
describe what this combinatorial
construction is
so post is just a linear assembly of
sets
meaning that you have some small such
other vertices like these guys then you
have some bigger subset of vertices that
include them like these guys then you
have even bigger
subsets and so on
and in this laminar family all of these
subsets are finite so
remember we are now talking about
descriptive combinatorics so we think
about an infiniti
so all of these subsets are finite and
also we can require that all of the kind
of the boundaries of these subsets are
at least few hops apart so here here is
the success to say that there are these
two options
and
this is something that this kind of
lemon family called toast this is
something
that you can construct in this crossbar
also i forgot to say one very important
thing so we have to require that every
vertex is at some point covered by some
subset in this seminar because otherwise
empty thermal isn't also this option
so once you have this
uh
this family of sets called toast you can
again construct
the solution to a perfect machine as
follows so you can say that
you can first look at the first class
that somehow is the smallest smallest
subset in my family and you can
basically
give some arbitrary solutions in these
small subsets so for example this guy is
much somehow outside here
then you take this perfect
this edge here and so on
and because these subsets have some
small distance then these solutions
although they can extend this small
subset a bit they will somehow always be
valid
and
now once you have constructed the
solution
in these in these small subsets you can
go one level higher
and you can accept the solution that you
currently have to these bigger subsets
so for example one thing that you can do
is that you do not look at all of those
vertices that are in the bigger subsets
but they are not solved yet and you
again solve them arbitrarily
and again because perfect matching is
helpful it has this powerful
combinatorial condition you can prove
that the solution always can be extended
and since it can be always extended you
can continue this construction countably
many times right you you have somehow
it's like comfortable hierarchy where
you have still bigger and bigger subsets
and after you do it comfortable
comfortably many times in the limit you
cover the whole tree and you have your
solution to perfect matching
so this is how you prove that perfect
matching is in this class codebear
and as you can see the two reasons why
perfect matching is
in
local or program and why it is in this
class there the two reasons are a little
bit different right they share some
similarities
for example both are some kind of
hierarchical constructions but they are
also a bit different so this is some
countable construction in this class
where we are talking about an infinite
tree
here this is some finite construction
that finishes after offloading steps
and
somehow these are important here and so
on
so these are given a little bit
different construction
and i hope that this kind of
helps us to kind of appreciate the fact
that we now actually understand
that the two classes are the same
somehow this class local opera is
somehow captured by this recon complex
construction
this part there is captured by this a
little bit different tools construction
but still both of these constructions
capture the same class as the ones
so i think that this is a quite
interesting fact
and let's now move on
to some other results that we prove in
the paper
sort of what we have seen so far we have
been discussing
uh this equality between homophobia and
bear
it turns out that something similar is
happening in the lower side of the
spectrum so there is this class called
continuous that has again
some
natural formulation that i will not go
into
and it turns out that this class of
local problems that you can define in
this field of descriptive common matrix
is exactly the same
as the class of problems you can solve
in rockstar and steps
and this is a result that's waiting for
this version
and it turns out that this is an
adaptation
of a proof idea
that was already taken by bernstein and
independently by steward
and relying on some it relies on some
results in descriptive combinatorics
that are even earlier
so let me just discover this thing a bit
because when we have been discussing
this equality of logan equal pair and we
were somehow super lucky
because it turned out that all the
problems in this class
actually have some simple combinatorial
characterization
but it turns out that this is not so in
difficulty
because this thing holds even in a
bigger generality it holds for example
if instead of trees we consider grids
however it is known that
in grids it is actually undecidable
to decide whether a problem is in this
class or not
so somehow we don't really have a very
good very very good grip or very good
understanding on
what makes a
problem
what makes a local problem to be in this
class local or folk style
but still we can prove that the class
captures
the same problems as this class of
continuous functions
so another reason why these
uh equalities are interesting
is that they can also the stuff was
actually proven
in both fields so there are some results
where we
know how to prove some some results in
distributed algorithms for example that
it is undecidable
uh
to say whether on grid's own core
problem
is in this case or not we also know that
it is undecidable in this class
continuous this was a separate result
and now we know that these two classes
are actually the same we need just one
proof right so it actually kind of
simplifies the picture you don't need to
prove for everything
[Music]
so
the picture looks really nice so far so
maybe you were thinking that it would
also be the case that the discard bottle
is the same as
this class in the middle that allows for
fast randomized algorithms
but this is actually not the case
so we prove in this paper that
this cardboard is incomparable in this
class on the left
and this forms from two results one is
actually again earlier result of marx
that implies that there exists a problem
that is in this card here but it is not
in this particular
and we complement it by an example
of a different problem which is in this
cardboard but it is not in this class
are going to look okay
so
the picture is is not so super nice that
there is
you know really something something new
that these descriptive combinatorics
classes are
are kind of adding
and actually it is even much more
complicated than this so this is the
picture from the paper
and
you can see here that there is like
another
another ellipse
that's talking about something called
factors of iids and uniform algorithms
which is like yet another exact field
that we consider and that we try to
link to these other two fields but i i
really couldn't talk about it during
this talk because it would take too much
time
so let me just mention that somehow the
picture is quite complicated there are
lots of certain problems
lots of questions to ask
also in this paper we introduce some new
concepts like the id graph trick and
prove some
new results that that are i think
interesting even if you care just about
local algorithms or even if you care
just about measure theoretical
constructions
but again i unfortunately do not have
time to go into that
so let me just finish here
and let me just kind of repeat what this
book was about so we have seen that
there is this model of distributed
algorithms in which you can define some
local complexities
and you can kind of
try to understand
the behavior of local problems
and then there is this other field
called descriptive combinatorics
there you can again try to understand
local problems but from a different
angle
the definitions are different
but it turns out that there are a lot of
connections and it seems that possibly
there could be a lot of things waiting
to discover or techniques that one can
bring some other field to another to be
the other one
so i think that this is all very
exciting
and if you want to chat about it with us
then
please contact us
thank you